لأنني كنت أقرأ بعض
الأدلة على أن الأشخاص الذين يشاهدون أفلام الرعب في
كثير من الأحيان كانوا أكثر
مرونة خلال الوباء ، فقد
كانوا أقل اكتئابًا وقلقًا
لأنهم كانوا أكثر سعادة وكان لديهم المزيد من
المعنى والغرض وأنت تعرف ربما
ربما كانوا أكثر مرونة في
البداية مثل حسنًا ، يمكنني التعامل مع فيلم رعب
ولكني أعتقد في الواقع أن هناك
القليل من ممارسة تنظيم المشاعر
التي تأتي مع مشاهدتك
تعرف ما إذا كان مكانًا هادئًا أو منشار تكساس
الذي تعرف أنك ستشعر به  الخوف في
حالة المخاطر المنخفضة حيث تعلم
أنه لا يوجد تهديد حقيقي والحصول على
التدرب على إدارته بمرور الوقت ، ربما
يساعدك ذلك على الجلوس مع الخوف بشكل صحيح
ثم إعادة صياغته والقول إنني
سأتعلم كيفية التعامل معه في هذه
المواقف الأقل تهديدًا والآن لدي
ثقة أكبر قليلاً في أنه يمكنني
التعامل معها في المواقف الأكثر خطورة
، وبطريقة ما كان هذا هو
عملك الصحيح ، لقد
تعاملت مع  مع الخوف وفي
المواقف الخطيرة حقًا ، لكنك
ربما تعاملت أيضًا مع بعض
الإصدارات الأقل رعبًا منها مثل أم
تعلم ،
أنا يجب أن ألتقط الكاميرا مرة أخرى بشكل
صحيح وأنا قلق من أن هذه
المحادثة  لن تمضي
بشكل مثالي وأتساءل عما إذا كانت
تلك اللحظات تلك من التدريب
التدريبي ، أعتقد أنها أصبحت تدربًا
على الشيء الحقيقي ، ما رأيك في
ذلك حسنًا ،
نعم ، أعتقد أن هذا صحيح ،
أعني أنني أفلام رعب مثيرة
السابق بنيامين آه الذي يربي ابني
معي أه يحب أفلام الرعب إنه
مهووس بها ، إنه يضع قائمة
بالفعل ذات يوم يأمل أن يتمكن من
مشاهدتها مع ابننا
أنا لا أحب أفلام الرعب لأنني
أشعر نوعًا ما بأن الحياة مخيفة
يكفي وأواجه أشياء مخيفة بما فيه الكفاية في
عملي أه ولدي طوال
الثلاثين عامًا الماضية من وظيفتي أو 25 عامًا
لا أحتاج إلى إضافة المزيد من الأشياء
التي تعرف الخوف أو الدراما أه في
وقتي خارج المنهج ولكني أجد
أنني أفكر
أجبر نفسي و  أو منذ وقت طويل
أعتقد أن هناك شيئًا ما يتعلق
بالتعرض لشيء ما
لإظهار أنه يمكنك أن أعني أنك لا تعرف أبدًا
كيف ستستجيب له في موقف
مخيف في موقف خطير حقًا
حتى تكون في  قد لا يكون
الأمر والطريقة التي تعتقد أنك قد تستجيب بها
تمامًا هي الطريقة
التي تستجيب
بها ،
وإذا كان بإمكانك الاستمرار في العمل في
شيء مخيف ، فقد وجدت
أنه لأني أجد ذلك قوة
حقيقية أعتقد ذلك  هذا تمييز رئيسي
لأن ما يحدث مع الكثير من
الأشخاص عندما يفعلون عندما يشعرون بالخوف
ما يفعله الكثير من الناس هو أنهم
يذهبون أساسًا إلى وضع القتال أو الهروب
، وبالنسبة للكثير منا ، فإن الاستجابة السهلة
هي تجنب ذلك
ولكن إذا  تتجنب الخوف باستمرار ،
فأنت لا تعرف حقًا ما تشعر به
وكأنك لا تفهم القبضة التي
يأخذها عليك ولا تقوم بتطوير
استراتيجيات لإدارتها بشكل أكثر
فاعلية ، وبالتالي فإن هذه الفكرة التي
تقول "حسنًا ، انتظر دقيقة"  أم ماذا لو
الآن حسنًا ، أخشى لماذا
أخشى ما الذي يمكنني فعله حيال ذلك
يجعل من الأسهل قليلاً
تنشيط بعض المعالجة ذات المستوى الأعلى
بدلاً من السماح للخوف
بالتحكم بك